Alexander volcanowski is a guy where
he's gotten bigger from this more people
root for him more people Saul's heart
now you now you realize how talented
volkanovsky is listen we're all high in
Yaya Rodriguez right now there's not a
45er that's ever lived who can beat
Alexander volkanovsky you're out of your
mind if you think any other 45er that's
ever lived could come up to 155 and do
well against Islam makjev and make it a
controversial split decision but a lot
of people think Alexander volcanovski
won that fight there ain't a one 145
that's ever stepped inside any cage on
any planet in the history of time that
could have gave makachev that much of a
fight you think Yaya Rodriguez is going
to beat him at 45 you're out of your
mind nobody's gonna be about 45
ever